bello a tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo primo video ieri ho già fatto un
video su fall guy di circa tre ore
perché era una live dove ho anche vinto
una partita alla fine se volete la
potete trovare sul canale questo video
che state per vedere invece l'ho
registrato la primissima volta che ho
giocato a polgai e lo metto a punto per
farvi vedere quali sono state le mie
prime impressioni su questo gioco perché
adesso sono molto più forte però è
bellissimo vedere come giocava
all'inizio perché mi piaceva un sacco
polgai ragazzi uscirà sul mio canale
tutti i lunedì e tutti i giovedì a
partire da questa settimana
quindi ragazzi mi raccomando seguitelo
sempre e buona visione
io guardo takeshi's castle con un
maledetto da bambino non vedevo l'ora
che uscisse un gioco più o meno simile
quasi qualifiche non solo i figli 40 le
slot non conta arrivare primo credo
perché ho fatto solo una partita o la
mia prima rosa arrivato settimo la mia
prima partita l'ho fatta prima per
vedere come si giocava su arrivato
settimo che non vale niente adesso
valente quale quando la giorgi parole
tg1 sono i 80
adesso vediamo la sclocco non ho neanche
capito bene i tasti quali sono perché
caso fa succedono cose no c'era un corso
per te dove saltare io che ne so non ho
capito male vero sono stato eliminato
secondo teste di culo la prima è andata
faceva schifo ary facciamo un'altra lega
allora di james mary kate olsen il resto
è ok non lo che io non so i tasti
ragazzo solo che possa andare ma non ci
sono in realtà tasti ce n'è solo uno che
non ho capito che cosa fa ma sembra che
proprio più quei davanti cuciti a snow
ed etoo fa un po in avanti ci sono
questo tasto perché non ho capito bene
che cantidati to find a matri pepe
però non ti fa aumentare di velocità di
strano come da basso va bene il 44 si
classificano qua va bene le cose
per ora tutto a posto è per ora non è
niente male tranne la palla lì porca
vacca che casino tagli di testa di culo
che bravo che la faccia ce la faccio non
stiamo andando male
ma neanche bene se un po medico avanti
non si può aumentare secolo mela la
velocità questa sembra tipo la pista tik
tok di mario kart è perfetto non è male
ragazzi sono tra i primi 20 secondo me
quindi questa è buona
perfetto vamonos vago no che ci sono le
palle alte
maledizione personaggio stupido ok no a
te ma porca trova veramente ce l'ha
fatta 20 22 22 siamo partiti bene 44
qualificati ragazze di oggi vediamo cosa
succede per adesso tutto che guarda
quanta roba incredibile che c'è ragazzi
abbandonate forti night su un pidocchio
essere sicuro che l'ultima viatico lo sa
e code riccò de non ho capito le cose
però sono quali sono ste cose non ho
capito cosa devo prendere le cose ce le
hanno attaccati gli altri ho capito
adesso lancia la gente che ha staccato
delle code pulitevi prendere le cose
l'ho preso a c'è una coda o una coda o
una cosa compagni delle palle prendete
le cose ho capito adesso resistere con
la pillola non avevo fatto niente ma non
fa niente tanto l'importante è arrivare
alla fine gioco io ho una coda quindi
ottimo non solo attento a non farvi
beccare agli altri
vi do una bella botta così perfetto
madonna e casinò non mi cagate non mi
prendete aiuto nessuno mi ha preso il
mio team a sei corde perfetto vai giravo
capire ciò che adesso delle code dal
cielo non stavo capendo questa si arriva
alla fine cottura la fonte teste di no
che è successo ma nessuno ma non è vero
ma non è vero ma non è vero ma io l'ho
preso presa a 543 che poi tu che ce
l'hai 21 io sono una coda il mio team
più code purificato e offerto a posto
madonna che anzi a rivivere fatta roba
c'è anche roche clip in mezzo cosa
succede come è possibile
ok devo ammettere più a uova possibile
nel mio certo va bene io sono sempre i
gialli paesi che bordello
che bordello finale io sto prendendo
solo i miei compagni del cup che io ho
preso sono qua perfetto non è solo messo
bravi di compagni forza ragazzi forza
forza forza ragazzi forza a perché poi
dobbiamo prendere le uova dagli altri
team giustamente doveva togliere dal
loro cestini
noi abbiamo 22 vi andiamo a saccheggiare
i blu il blu tutti contro i blu che
eliminiamo in blu chissenefrega il blu
devono avere veramente pochi punti tutti
fuori allora eliminiamo buttiamo solo le
uova fuori neanche portare dentro
bastare montiamo fuori non ce l'abbiamo
giusto importante quello e due hanno
rubato le europee ragazzi occhio alle
nostre basi ci sono i blu dentro stesse
di pigna ragazzi qualcuno in difesa
qualcuno in difesa che ci dai i rossi
hanno troppa roba da vada visto nuovo
pezzo di merda vai vai vai se siamo
tutti in cui la stessa attuata cioè
senza squadra testa di culo
la stessa squadra questa dammi luogo ok
a posto
via pia voler alba i cori con ringuet
regista bravo
ok ok ok mancano i secondi live 26 siamo
fuori cavillo l'igloo hanno un nuovo
solo spende anche portate glielo fuori
di acqua o vino fuori dalle palle via
anche qui dentro è bello sto gioco
perché non ti puoi mettere il dinner in
the lo segna lui io sono falgha iv 1082
che lo segna lui non puoi avere il
nickname
credo non te lo puoi modificare beh figo
se con gli assi 20 però di non fare roba
con team prema eliminazione singolo e da
qui ragazzi devo raggiungere il
traguardo schivando la frutta che scende
si classifica dei primi 12 madonna
questa rinizia diventare complicato e
ragazzi correte correte correte corro io
e basta
ciao ragazzi aiuto non saltato non è
impossibile
evidente che arrivata non saprò mai o
forse ce la faccia al pelo no una
fragola delle palle d'oro ce la faccio
eliminato mannaggia al vicolo maggio al
vicolo è arrivata una fragola della min
ci siamo ragazzi nuova partita nuovi
avversari nuove cose bene a questo lo
avevo fatto per per testare un po il
gioco
la prima volta queste queste sono porte
che si sfondano alcune sì altre nozze
classifica dei primi 40 se non sbaglio
quindi alcuni sono tutte uguali le porte
alcune si sfondano al treno
randomicamente le coop
i primi 42 vano vai porca vacca sfondate
le porte ecco qua secondo me non
conviene andare primi subito perché ha
meno veicoli che si aprono e poi ti
butti in quanto come questo aspettare un
attimo conviene madonna che porta e poi
cosa dico madonna che ha casinò i 6000
tutti la poi quando ti colpiscono i
tanti tu non puoi fare niente
calcolatori boero è la sma donna
bellissima e se si è di 60 scaricatelo
facciamo un gioco una partita solo
iscritti porca vacca bellissimo click
parade naviga tra sugli ostacoli e vai
verso aggiunge questo è uno molto
classico quindi sono ostacoli e arriva
al traguardo
let's go bellissimo speriamo che
facciano uscire altre mappe poi dlc
qualche roba e meraviglio voglio giocare
questo tutto il giorno cosa farci ai
quattro occhio raga teste dini sapevo a
posso andare a chi sa che risolto la
seconda è di chiara meglio passati
software suo primo sanremo sono senato
agli uffici specchi qui da otto team no
no quella rossi gira di qua h anch'io no
madonna regalo
signorini olivia ce l'ho fatta ce l'ho
fatta vai verso la vittoria verso quella
però nicchia settimo quali file ex
ragazzi bellissimo il rock and roll
bush il bolton e finish line di foglio
del m'inchino ragazzi questi edifici
ragazzi nostro team di essere coordinato
spaziale come una tesla deve venire kg
mask ad applaudirci non sono i blu io
che schifo vabbè il forza blu vigente
sfuggente come di trogloditi va ai
ragazzi vai così chi se ne frega va e va
bene va bene che siamo primi vai forza e
coraggio e formaggio bravo e mezzo in
mezzo il metodo bravi ragazzi non lo
fece un palo di ceppaloni a sinistra a
sinistra dove cazzo date bravi bravi
bravi bravi bravi a destra e stava ai
consumi bravi l'ultimo reti lido vai non
di chi gira lui non si cela provocato la
falla si destinano scambiato i gialli
aiuto la falla bloccate buttala sei
bravissimo ma ecco team accadeva che si
è andata ragazzi che garanzia ho sudato
freddo e stato orribile
paul martin ricede troppo demonte in
free stays ok ok questo è il final round
vince solo uno e bisogna prenderla
corona ok ho capito c'è un sacco di urla
palle palle aiuto primo che vengono
demoliti tutti quanti c'è una palla lì
oddio oddio oddio la guerra bio sono
ancora i piedi non ancora niente detto
bene bene bene così bene così dai
sbagliano questi alla fine dai blocchi
non diventi no arrivato un altra parte
porca [ __ ] ero tra i primi cinque serie
già sono contento perché ho fatto un
partitone ora era alle mie prime cioè
mai giocato a roma e del suo look
arrivato in finale
ragazzi questo era forca in gioco
pazzesco spero che vi piaccia perché
portero 65.000 episodi punto
[Musica]
iscriviti al canale presente